[Music]
you know being a businessman or woman
wasn't cool in 1992 it was Bill Gates
you know like nerd so now that everybody
wants to put entrepreneurship in their
Instagram profile and that's cool in the
club that is just Bizarro world but
that's also done what sports and rapping
has which is everybody wishes they are
and what's different about
entrepreneurship Than Rap and sports is
when you say you're a rapper someone's
like all right rap and then if you suck
everyone's like oh you suck you know and
when you say you're a basketball player
people are like at the YMCA or or going
to the league but when somebody now says
they're an entrepreneur it's just
accepted and we we haven't matured into
are you a successful entrepreneur or
want to be entrepreneur you know to be
very Frank I'm concerned about it
because I think the one thing I love
about entrepreneurship is it's binary
either you're gonna win or you're gonna
lose and I think that there's a lot of
people right now that are not built with
dealing with the emotional baggage that
comes along with a public loss so I
spent a lot of time with young
entrepreneurs around the mentality of
like when you lose you know are you
ready to take that ridicule and what are
you going to do the greatest reason I
believe that we're living through such
fake entrepreneurship right now is not
only is there an enormous amount of
capital in play for these 20 to 25 year
olds but they're the generation that was
parented in a way that tried to
eliminate losses from the ecosystem I
mean this is the generation of eighth
place trophies right hey it's Evan
Carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some motivation to outwork
everyone
enjoy
[Music]
my favorite thing that's going on in
society right now is 45 to 60 year olds
you know clowning on Millennials and
making fun of them and I keep looking at
them and I keep reminding them that you
parented these kids
everybody gets a trophy right yeah I
mean and so you know we've demonized to
these kids losing I love losing like
micro losing especially more than macro
losing is incredibly motivating you know
I mean there's nothing more fun than
losing regular season games right you
know you learn from them you know come
the playoffs you'd like to build on that
um but yeah I mean I I think adversity
is the foundation of success being born
in the Soviet Union living in a studio
apartment with eight family members when
I was a kid going on one and a half
vacations my entire childhood my parents
buying me nothing because they didn't
have like the money nor the mindset to
do that for me is fundamentally the
reason I'm successful at
entrepreneurship I'm not scared of
anything nor do I care about anybody
else's judgment which allows me to
navigate very quickly and my losses are
my losses and my wins are my wins and
they both feel the same when I hear the
accolades or when I get razzed I
basically can't hear them I'm just so in
love with the process
and that's and that's what getting up
off the floor is you had no choice you
just it's in your DNA to want to play
I'm wondering what's the message to a
company that that doesn't have
Innovation as a core part of their
business how do they respond
by letting themselves die but what do
they do if they don't want to die
innovate and how do they do that what's
the secret
by looking at the leader of the company
in the mirror and see if she or he is
capable of innovating
everything stems from the top
if you run if you have a company run by
somebody who right now is sitting and
saying well I'm retiring in 18 months
and I don't give a [ __ ] about Innovation
you're in trouble
or not talented enough to know how to
innovate
like you know how many a's number ones
hire a CMO and say you figure it out but
they don't even know how to judge it how
are you a CEO in 2019 and don't spend
100 hours to educate yourself on how
modern communication works so that you
can judge it within your own
organization
Gary I didn't grow up with this stuff
you didn't grow up driving you figured
it out like I know you didn't grow up
with it but it is your job
to it's required of you to know how to
run your business and to me how your
business markets and communicates is as
important as you knowing how to run the
finances of your company it's just that
some people don't want to put in the
work to get updated on the new platforms
and the new world and that's to their
Peril the advice that I think will play
for everybody in the room regardless of
what you do including if like you're the
PTA president or thinking about running
for local office like I have no idea
what you want to do professionally or
personally but the one thing that has
been tried and true and I keep things
extremely simple is you have to reverse
engineer the audience you're trying to
reach and you have to tell them
something that brings them value not you
value every single person here that is
empowered to do so needs to go spend the
next 100 days having phone calls having
dinner having breakfast having drinks
with every one of their customers and
they need to listen to what they care
about and they need to go back to the
pad and cook that meal
that's all I do I read my comments
you know left and right like you know I
was just talking with your CMO prepping
you know you were you guys were wrapping
up and she's like are you always like
this on your phone and I was laughing
what I was doing I was reading comments
yeah because the qualitative feedback is
the Insight I need for the next
Innovation and the amount of people who
hope their customers like what they are
doing or they're trying to force their
customers to like what they want to sell
is fascinating for me to watch you
talked about this is that people who are
who are dragging down the culture of a
business should be they shouldn't be
there that's right I wish most
businesses were into documenting and
Coach what most businesses are doing is
Harold's but his numbers are remarkable
yeah that's what's really happening
that's what I'm referring to that if
you've got somebody who's driving top
line revenue or is she or he is crushing
their numbers
what most companies are doing is they're
looking at surface level they're like oh
if we fire Carol we're going to lose
those three accounts because she's so
wired in there what they don't realize
is the hidden lost Revenue that's
happening with Carol or Harold
destroying the culture and completely
messing up the continuity and speed of
the background so what do you do from
your point of view what do you do if you
have if you have someone who's really
kicking ass bringing the numbers in and
they're just they're a jerk what do you
do with them what I do and one one man's
point of view is I sit them down I look
them dead in the face and I say you
think I'm joking because you're
delivering but I'm not joking and if you
can't be a good human being I'm going to
fire your face
[Music]
that's that's pretty right there right
that's what I do and I do it and I do it
you know I'm a big shot on stage now and
I'm acting tough I do it I do it in a
conversation I'm like look I'm not
kidding like I know you don't believe me
because you've worked in other places
that value dollars and I value dollars I
just value slow dimes right so when you
deliver on culture the buy-in and the
macro is remarkable and what it does for
the business is extraordinary I'm a I'm
a pot committed buyer of this thesis
that you have to fire
the best performers that are destroying
your culture rule number two is get your
money right with Grant Cardone hey I got
a question for you what if you could 10x
your income
think about it how much would your life
change
it'd change a bunch wouldn't it first
time I was asked that question it rocked
my life I was making 60 Grand a year I
lived in Lake Charles Louisiana I was in
debt
to working my butt off every day and the
guy said what if you could 10x your
income Grant oh by the way my name is
Grant Cardone and I have done that
I have 10x my income that question when
the guy asked me that question I said
that's impossible no way I could
possibly do that I was many many years
ago
and at 60 Grand a year I'm like man if I
made if I made first I said it's
impossible and then I said to myself but
what if well he moved on and that
question sat with me and it sat with me
now for 25 years
what if I could 10x my income
I didn't know how to do it who I would
talk to the business I was in definitely
there was nobody in that space that was
doing that kind of income
and I just kept asking myself it haunted
me what if I could 10x my income
man what if I could Graham what if I
could what would I have to do who would
I need to meet what would I need to
learn
so uh the first year the first 12 months
after that question was asked to me I
did not just to be completely
transparent and honest
I did not 10x my income
but I did 350 000.
I didn't 10x it uh what is that 7X
and and all of a sudden I got all this
enthusiasm now over the years I've
continued to ask myself that question
because I know it starts with the mind I
think you'd agree with that
if I think small I get small I'm going
to give you a free training below okay
reason I'm telling you this is there is
a possibility once you have the right
mindset the right strategies and the
right vehicle you have to have those
three things in place and a fourth thing
you need to be surrounded by the right
people first the right think you got to
start thinking about hey what if I could
like you don't even need to know how in
the beginning and I'm going to give you
this training because I want to see how
many people I can actually help to think
like this like this guy helped me think
like this
since then I mean this year we'll
probably do
I mean
I'm making that every month on just my
passive income from Real Estate
uh this is a long time ago now this
didn't happen overnight but I just kept
thinking about what could I do to 10x
660 000 to 350 350 to 3.5 million three
and a half million to 35 million 35
million yes
350 million in a year
how do you do it
what's the strategy once I get my head
right what's the strategy three am I
even in the right vehicle or do I need
to add other vehicles you you know most
people that make it to that level they
don't have one vehicle they got multiple
Vehicles so in this training what I'm
going to share with you is these four
critical ingredients one how do I get
this right
can't get this right for a second it
takes a it takes a minute and then you
gotta work on it again tomorrow how do I
work on my mental how do I protect my
mental so that I start thinking big so
difficult it's so hard
for those of us who are brought up maybe
in poverty scarcity
that mindset where you know you never
get a break
and I quit looking for opportunities and
if you're not looking you're not going
to see it
if you're not asking you're not going to
get it
so one I'm going to help you with the
mindset in our 10x income system Okay
click the link below grab this program
it's completely free there's no strings
attached I'm merely literally just
passing on doing for you what this guy
had done for me by asking me a great
question second thing I'm going to work
with you on is the strategy what
strategy people use it's not very
dissimilar most people are doing the
same things that 10x their income they
get out of that little space that spot
maybe you're stuck at 100 or 80 or 30.
uh maybe you're a waitress or a waiter a
bartender
maybe you own a restaurant man you just
can't get ahead right now because uh
because all the stuff that's going on in
the world
look I went from
working for somebody getting fired from
Seven jobs not one job seven jobs to
today owning 11 companies
two billion dollars worth of real estate
I know it sounds freaking impossible
like come on man that's impossible I
know that's what I thought
so
um
we're going to show you the strategy I'm
going to show you the exact strategy you
need I don't know how to turn my car up
let me show you the exact strategy you
need and then we're going to look at the
vehicles the vehicles that can actually
produce that kind of income most people
are simply in the wrong space you just
can't scale out enough to get where you
want to go and the last thing is is to
pass my bag out here can you help me
with that
the last thing is who do you need to be
connected with long term because you're
going to have to change your friends
you're going to have to I don't I don't
mean get rid of the friends and family
that you have but you're going to have
to add some new friends new family new
peeps a new network you know they say
your network is your network hey guys
well that's true for you to keep scaling
10xing 60.
600 6 million it's all possible I
promise you if I can do it you can do it
I went from being a guy that was a
one-man show one-man show to running
companies I got a 200 employees here 350
in our real estate uh Partners all
around the world and it's only because
of these four things I'm going to share
with you in the 10x income system which
is
first middle second and second is hey
what is my strategy to get to the next
level three three is am I in the right
vehicle picking the right Vehicles okay
real estate's a great vehicle uh
coaching's a great Vehicle Health Care
is a great vehicle
um uh education is a great vehicle I'm
in all these but by the way right now
using online today the metaverse is
going to open up all kind of
opportunities for so many people I'll be
right there webinars online uh
phenomenal opportunity for everybody out
there if you're in the situation right
now you don't like it you don't like
where you're at you don't like what
you're doing you're limited you're stop
you're stuck okay grab this take
advantage of it okay I'm telling you
it's a game changer it's going to give
you what you need what you need
what you need so that you can have what
you deserve everybody deserves a great
life everybody deserves the ability the
ability these guys will go crazy if I
come in here okay you deserve the
ability to um morning
uh to uh
they make more money period because the
truth is if you don't make more money
you'll never have money to invest and
you'll never get to the second Hustle
the third one the fourth one you'll
never get to the multiple flows rule
number three be prepared for failures of
mermaid Sethi how many people do you
think are getting pulled in in a way
that's exciting like hey now you've got
17 year olds creating YouTube content
around Investments which is real and I
am utterly shocked by that and how much
of this is like oh my God we're heading
towards a cliff
um thank you
that's a great question okay let me
start off with what happened with my
first Investments so here it is it's
around 1999 2000 everybody thinks
they're a tech genius you put money in
any stock it goes up 26 the next day
so what do I do I take my college
scholarship money and I put some of it
in the stock market thinking
this is easy 19 20 yeah guarantee and
every day it's going up and down but
mostly up was there a massive view for
you I wasn't focused yes at all yes
everybody
was everybody believed they're a genius
so in a bull market everybody believes
they're a genius and
um they all say the same phrase This
Time It's Different it's so fun it's
it's such a funny phrase that in the
investment world people make fun of it
it's a they're mocked because it's never
different it's actually the same thing
bubbles expand uh but over time they
mathematically cannot continue so here
we have people making millions of
dollars who would otherwise be working
in a parking garage and they are giving
stock tips out and telling everybody you
got to get into this jdsu this you know
all kinds of stuff
so I take my college scholarship money
put it in the market and
I very quickly lose half the money
because of the crash yeah or because of
the crash and so what happens is I
realize oh my God I'm not as smart as I
thought it's not easy to become a
millionaire through investing in two
weeks and so here is where there was a
pivotal moment one I could have doubled
down and said I just picked the wrong
stock let me pick another stock this is
very similar to what you hear with
people in the crypto World well my
investment quote investment dropped 50
but you know I got to do this coin or
that coin Etc
what I chose to do is go different and
say you know what
I don't think I'm that smart about
investing and I actually want to learn
how fundamental basic investing works so
things like low cost long-term things
like reading about John bogle's
philosophy
Etc
and I started to learn about it also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four learn the physics
of progress with Tom bilyeu what is the
biggest needle mover for moving your
business forward in your experience what
can I do if I feel like my startup is
not moving fast enough
okay
whenever you're trying to build a
business you are saying I'm here I have
a goal that's there your goal needs to
be hyper specific
between me and my goal is an obstacle
and I need to get past that obstacle now
to get past that obstacle you're looking
for what Tim Ferriss calls the lead
Domino I think this is a brilliant
concept you're looking for that thing
that you can do first that if you do
that that's going to have the biggest
knock-on effect in terms of making other
things easier so at impact Theory I'm
trying to build the next Disney my lead
Domino with social media my set so the
reason I wanted that was I needed people
to know who I was so that I could
attract Talent so that I could go get
doors open for me in Hollywood because
people had seen my content and I knew
that that was going to be a chain that
worked for me because that is one of the
talents that I've just put a lot of time
and energy into is the ability to
articulate ideas for people so I just
had a feeling that I'd be able to build
a big social ecosystem it just worked
out exactly like that and because of
that I've been able to get meetings and
open doors that I never would have been
able to do before now the second Lee
Domino is
video content being competent at
creating visual content because if we're
going to be the next Disney we know that
we're going to be dealing in uh film TV
video games
um storytelling books Comics all of that
okay so all right cool so if I know that
that's what I'm gonna have to do what
are those areas of core competency one
was going to be video content another
was going to be comic books those are
the first that we attacked for several
other reasons but identifying what your
core competencies are going to need to
be and that if I were to get those core
competencies they would necessarily make
it easier for me to do other things okay
that's what you want to identify now
once you have that you're going to run
something that I call the physics of
progress and I actually teach a whole
class on this uh in Impact Theory
University in something called business
decision making so if you guys have a
business already and you're looking to
scale it go check out business decision
making we go into into a lot of depth on
this but the idea is as follows there is
a an actual nature to progress there is
a way that it works now the reason I
call it the physics of progress is
because it's getting down to First
principles thinking now what first
principles thinking is you're no longer
reasoning by analogy okay we're not
saying this is something that's like
this we're saying this is it this is the
thing this is how it works so take the
Human Experience for instance The Human
Experience the first principle's way to
view it is that humans are the result of
evolution and when you understand how
Evolution shape the brain and the body
and how they're in communication now the
human animal suddenly becomes a lot less
mysterious and you don't have to wonder
where that negative Voice is coming from
or why you're so ambitious why you're
afraid of public speaking all of those
things you could understand from a first
principle's perspective of understanding
how Evolution shaped Us in business
there are very similar physics right
you're trying to sell something for more
than it costs you to make it to scale
you're going to have to have employees
employees or humans and they have all
kinds of what Dan arieli calls
predictable uh they're predictably
irrational so looking at all of that
understanding how markets move
understanding how marketing Works
understanding the tools you're going to
use in your business understanding
business structure when you understand
all of those things now you can think
from first principles when we talk about
making progress there are very simple
steps that you have to do and it's
basically the science method
recontextualized for business and it
goes like this
I'm here my goal is there I have
identified the obstacle the impediment
that stands between me and my goal and a
way that I like to ask it is why if I
just keep doing what I'm doing now why
won't I automatically get to my goal
and one of the most important things to
understand is the second law of
Thermodynamics which applies
aggressively to business which states
that any closed system moved toward
moves towards entropy meaning
that if you don't have energy coming
into a system everything goes towards
chaos right your room becomes messy
um the fire burns out like or the forest
fire rages across everything
moves towards chaos and the only way to
organize something to structure it to
get it to work in a specific way is to
pump energy into that system right to
get a plant to grow you must bombard it
with photons basically radiation from
the sun right so for a human to grow you
have to eat sustenance and so we're
literally
translating the energy from the Sun into
food to create this body which we then
have agency and can do things and one of
those things that we're going to do in a
business context is figure out where do
we have to apply energy to make sure
that we overcome whatever obstacle
stands between us and our goal
so you identify that obstacle then
you're going to come up with your best
hypothesis so it's just the best guess
on what you would need to do to most
effectively overcome that obstacle
what's that lead Domino what's the thing
that if I do that it's going to move me
most meaningfully towards my goal
then once you have that best guess and
it is just a guess then you're going to
actually formulate and run an experiment
it's going to be something that you can
do it's not something that you think
about so for instance let's say
that uh I know that I want to grow my
YouTube channel and let's say I want to
buy uh December 31st I want to have a
million views per day by December 31st
2021 on YouTube Okay cool so now what's
the best thing that I could do in order
to get there I might have a couple ideas
uh maybe I need to bring on better
guests that have bigger reach or maybe
it's my thumbnail and uh my copy okay
now as it turns out our hypothesis was
uh both of those were important but
believe it or not that the thing that's
most important because you can have the
right guess but if you have the wrong
thumbnail and headline you're in real
trouble
now if you have all the right thumbnails
and headlines with the wrong guests
you're also in trouble but the lead
Domino is getting that thumbnail and
headline right making sure that you're
feeding the algorithm so that the
YouTube algorithm supports your content
then you've got an opportunity to get
the right guest in front of more people
and then when the two synergistically
happen it it explodes but just to stick
with one of the things we actually ran
was this thumbnail in headline okay so
we had all the different experiments
that we wanted to run we picked the one
that we thought was the most likely to
move us forward using something that's
known as the ice method ice so impact
confidence and ease what's the impact if
it works what's my confidence that it
will work and how easy will this be to
implement so we came up with those
different things we were going to test
on the thumbnail those become the
experiments the levers as I call them
that we're going to pull we're actually
going to pull that lever meaning put
that new approach to thumbnails and
headlines out into the world then we're
going to get a result from The Real
World and we're going to analyze that
data then we're going to have learned
something once we learn something we
will refine our hypothesis and begin the
process again
and that Loop is the physics of progress
okay let me walk you through that one
more time
I know I have a problem
I come up with a hypothesis on the most
efficient way to solve that problem I
come up with a way to test that
hypothesis a thing I'm going to do in
this case put out new headlines and
thumbnails and then I'm going to see
what the result is from The Real World
in this case it worked tremendously well
we tried many many things many of them
failed but many of them worked that was
the data that we analyzed that refined
our approach in terms of what thumbnail
and headline changes we wanted to make
and we did that over and over and over
and over and in doing that we have more
than doubled our view count over the
testing period okay that's a massive win
for us and just came from running the
physics of progress over and over and
over and it doesn't matter what area of
your business hey guests what kind of
guests should we have on here is my best
guess so we should go into XYZ space uh
okay that didn't work we should try this
base and then the one that's really
popping off for us right now and of
course this will change over time but
cryptocurrency nfts that's there's so
much energy pouring into that space
right now doing a lot of content there
because I happen to have a passion for
it and I'm researching the [ __ ] out of
it so we try doing that content marry
that with the changes and boom it
literally the graph on our YouTube page
looks like uh it's almost a straight
line up it's ridiculous but it was all
the work that we did over here is we're
learning learning learning learning
learning and then it's like we finally
begin to optimize and it goes up and to
the right but first you have to run all
those tests fail over and over and over
but as I mentioned failure is the most
information Rich data stream that exists
so in all of those little failures we
were learning refining our approach
which allowed us to get better which
then ultimately gave us the results rule
number five know the elements with Ed
mylett the most powerful force in the
history of the world is religion right
and I'm not talking about building
something that's important as someone
finding God but I am talking about
building the same elements see Rick
Warren and the purpose-driven life wrote
this great book book was the best
selling book of all time other than the
Bible and in that book he lists five
things that are sort of the keys
purposes to a religion right I thought
it was interesting so I'm gonna give you
what those five keys were because I
think they applied a business I think
they applied a family so we're going to
listen to Rick Warren's five things I'm
going to give them to you right now and
then I'm gonna tell you they apply to
business for you being Evangelical and
creating a religious cult-like following
for your company and your products which
is what you all want so those five
things are Fellowship
two discipleship and education three
worship four Ministry and service and
five evangelization these are the five
purposes of religion that he lists in
The Purpose Driven Life so how does that
apply to business let's start with
Fellowship you want to create Fellowship
in your business you want to create a
community type environment for your
clients and the people that work with
you because people want to belong in
life number one need for human beings is
the need to belong so if you're not
creating that in the atmosphere around
your company again if it's a dry
cleaners what do you do when they walk
in to make them feel like they're part
of a community things you say things you
give them signs that are on the wall it
begins to build a community if you have
a financial services business or a real
estate business or a tech business or a
nutrition business what are you doing to
build community around your business
could that be your social media your
website your environment the workplace
the things you mail to your clients
thanking them what are you doing to
build community or Fellowship in your
business number two is discipleship or
education what are you doing to build
disciples is what does your company
believe in what does this stand for
what's the action that you want to give
them the way you build people who are
raving fans and followers as they know
what you stand for they know what you
believe in they know what your mission
is this is the way that you begin to
build sort of disciple type following
and the second thing is education every
business can be teaching somebody
something and that's another way you
build raving fans and building disciples
is by teaching them something so your
business ought to have an educational
slant to it in some way you need to be
thinking through how you begin to create
that in your business by teaching people
things and that could be just a value
problem it's gonna be something you
stand for be something you mail them
something you teach them but it begins
to build discipleship and education in
your business the third purpose of
religion that Rick list is worship and
we do want people to kind of be in our
presence and our business being that in
love with who we are and what we do and
religion they worship a Creator in your
business they're going to worship your
cause and your mission and what you
stand for and so it's got to be
constantly messaged all the time in some
way shape perform worship is a strong
word for really believe strong word is
to really be connected or strong word to
believe that you're different and unique
and special and cause oriented people
want to be a part of a movement just so
you know even as a consumer that's why
you see people wear the t-shirts of
different brands anything they can do to
say I belong here and I belong here
because I worship or I believe in the
cause I believe in the mission I believe
in what this company stands for that
could be what the leader stands for the
product stands for the delivery stands
for the industry stands for but they
need to know what you stand for for his
ministry and service is one of the
purposes that lists for religion and
that's also true for a business
businesses exist to solve a problem your
messaging needs to all the time be about
the service that you do because it's how
you mobilize people you mobilize people
around that mission you can hear the
common theme Here of dream Mission and
recognition and inside this what are you
doing to recognize the people that are
in your service for example in a church
if you've ever been to a church there
are people who get identified roles
don't they there's the pastor or the
priest or the rabbi Etc and whatever the
religion is there's also the ushers
there's the people who do the signings
there's the people who lead worship
service who play the music these are
forms of recognition inside the
organization what are you doing to
recognize your client what are you doing
to recognize your colleagues recognize
your recruits at every level all the
time this is how we begin to build this
part of the element of our cult-like
religious following and then lastly
evangelization think about all the
people who you maybe think are some of
the best business people or most
influential people you know everybody
from and they're different think about
this from Martin Luther King to Oprah
Winfrey to Mark Cuban to Steve Jobs to
Mark Zuckerberg to Elon Musk through the
guy I see on TV all the time he's seen
this guy with the pillow my pillow the
guy with the mustache and the blue shirt
and the cross studies I don't even know
the guy's name but he's like Evangelical
for his cause away his pillow will help
you sleep better and he repeats it over
and over and over again this this is a
part of building that religious
cult-like following as being Evangelical
about your company all the time what do
they all have in common because they're
all different people maybe you look at
me this way maybe it's one of your
favorite Business Leaders right one of
your favorite influencers
they have that element we all look
different we all talk different but we
all had a cause that we preached over
and over again by the way in no way
shape or form am I equating the my
pillow guy with my hero Martin Luther
King or am I equating Oprah Winfrey with
myself my point is is that any great
leader I'm talking about the best
restaurant in your town There's an
experience when you go in there and
that's the part of it I want you to
understand there's got to be an
experience in your family to make it
special there's got to be an experience
of being in that household whether it's
where you go or the the environment in
your home or just the spirit that's
inside your home that's an experience
people want to have a great experience
that they do business with right so what
experience are you creating when they
walk in your restaurant how do they feel
from the very beginning they meet with
you to the end of their meal what's the
experience that you want them to have in
your business the transaction they make
if you're saying the financial services
business what's the experience that you
want them to have
think that through for a minute from the
minute they meet you through their
entire lifetime with you what's the
experience feel like because if you want
referrals which is what you say you want
you want new people people refer people
when the experience is blissful when the
experience is amazing when the
experience is unique think about the
places or businesses you do business
with right now that you love the most
your favorite restaurant your favorite
clothing brand your favorite uh
influencer on social media hopefully me
right so what's the experience like how
do they make you feel when you're in
their restaurant when you're consuming
their protein product and maybe that
whole experience is how you order it how
you buy it the note they write you my
friend Andy for Stella my business
partner they're so specific at first one
but when you buy that product everybody
gets a handwritten note there's an
experience that's different than just
getting it shipped to you they're
creative and how they make people feel
even if it's in a benign transaction
like a dry cleaners right like a
sandwich shop but it's really important
in every business to just make the
experience of doing business with you
slightly different and more enjoyable
and pleasurable than everybody else in
today's world what distinguishes you
more than anything is the experience
it's all the things we've talked about
it's the Dream It's the cause it's the
Crusade it's the recognition it's all of
that wrapped up in what's the experience
that people are having when they're with
us because that's what they will
recommend to people is the experience
what makes a great family is the
Experience day to day of that family
it's never perfect right there's ups and
downs but what's the spirit and
experience in that family as a mother
what you're creating what's the
experience you're creating as a father
for your family as a business leader
what's the experience as a pastor of a
church what's the experience there for
when they walk in to when they walk out
to when they get home and you connect
with them through social media or
however you connect with them what's the
experience of doing business with you
these are the elements of creating a
movement of creating anything great
these are the ways I believe that you
create a great family a great baseball
team a great girl scout troop Boy Scout
Troop church or business these are the
elements that create that kind of
following and that greatness about what
you're doing you can do something great
with your life you were born to do
something great with your life yes you
drive it in your car right now having
that bad day on the treadmill right now
man just things aren't going the way you
want right now maybe you're watching
this on YouTube going like hey man I
don't even have a business right now I'm
not even sure I am a good dad I haven't
it doesn't matter your past does not
equal your future you were put here to
do something great in big ways and small
ways you're supposed to help other
people you're supposed to make a
difference you matter listen to me you
matter your past does not equal your
future here's the good news your
president doesn't equal your future
either your cable at any time of turning
your life around and if no one's
reminded you lately let me remind you
you're supposed to do something great
you're called to Greatness you're called
to something higher than where you are
right now and if some of these elements
that matter in doing it but more than
anything what matters is you knowing it
you know in your favor you know you can
do something great you know you're not
out of time you know you can turn your
life around I know it now you need to
know it in fact you need to know it
deeply because it's true rule number six
Master marketing with Dean graziosi
marketing tip number one I'm gonna go
through these kind of quick
marketing one
is one that I see happen all the time
and it's speak their language
speak their language
there them is your ideal client it's
your avatar it's the person that's gonna
you know your prospect
here's what happens
have you guys ever seen somebody in your
field or a teacher or a professor
write a book
that was written to impress their peers
all the time I saw you say that all the
time they write it to look like I don't
mean they don't do it on purpose it's
not like they're bad I'm gonna posture
but it's kind of like posturing it's
kind of showing your knowledge showing
your experience look what I've done look
what I've discovered look what I've
created they write a book to kind of
show what they've learned
and like three people read it that go
wow they're smart and no one else does
because it's over their head
if you here's the way I want you to look
at it if you write a book that is one
percent over their head
you're done how about you I listen to
books because I have ADD I have uh I
have ADD but I have a dyslexia so I have
to listen I know within the first two
chapters I'm taking this one all the way
to the end I've finished most every book
I listen to but I don't go past two
chapters on some if someone tries to
talk to me like they're smarter or they
use a tech term that I gotta go Google
because I don't know what the hell it
means I'm out because you're not talking
to me you're talking to maybe where I
could be someday but I'm not there now I
wanna listen I've been geeking out for
the last like year on really
understanding Investments right
inflation come in depreciation we got
the stock market that's been a up market
for way too long you know that there's
got to be a shift I really want to
understand it in a different way so I've
interviewed a lot of people and I've
read a lot of books to really understand
you know when you start making money you
want your money to work for you too
right you want to your partner should be
money right so I really wanted to
understand so I I've interviewed so many
people Tony's obsessed on it
and there's some books that I read and I
love when someone writes a book that
speaks to me as I'm a businessman I feel
like I'm fairly smart but I don't
understand certain
uh you know Tech jargon and certain and
if someone gets in the book and I'm in
chapter one and there's four or five
things that I just don't get I'm out
Never Gonna read the book
it's the same with marketing it's the
same with when you do the education when
we want to Market
talk to the person you used to be
there's a saying that I've been saying
for 20 years and it's going to be really
dumb to you but you know I share
everything with you I say make it so low
the goats can eat it
I don't know where it came from it's
kind of dumb but it reminds me when I'm
doing marketing or I'm doing a video
right I can jump on a video and say hey
knowledge Brokers it's time to share
what you know your expertise your hobby
let's go impact lives and make money
what about the brand new person it's
like what the freak is a knowledge
broker I don't talk about knowledge
broker in my ads when you guys are a
part of the self-education Revolution
I'll introduce what I believe a
knowledge broker is you have knowledge
you should broker to other people impact
their lives get paid makes sense now
right you're smiling oh I get that but
you'll never see me started and say how
would you like to be a knowledge broker
what the hell's that mean we want to
make it so low the goats can eat it on
every level meaning don't do Tech jargon
don't try to posture you don't have to
prove how smart you are you have to
prove that you care and that you can
give them the path and the plan to where
they want to go
does that make sense
some of you that are most of you are way
smarter than me um but some of you in
your area in your field of expertise
there are certain acronyms that you use
none of us have any idea what it is if
you're using an acronym
don't because I have no clue like it
doesn't mean anything to me and it takes
you out of the moment so marketing tip
number one speak so low the goats can
eat it speak to the person you used to
be before you became the expert before
you went through the experience does
that make sense
these are the subtle little things
you'll always see in my ads I think
sometimes people look at it and go wow
that was simple but they're clicking on
them my videos my audios okay number two
I know you know this but now that we're
evolving I want to remind you of this
we have to obsess on understanding our
clients pain
and what they want to run away from
and what's their pleasure where they
want to run towards and if you want to
break it up into those two buckets
it's pain
what is your what do your clients want
to move away from
pleasure where do they want to go to
here's what happens sometimes I want you
to hear this when you're on the other
side
when your arthritis is gone when your
business is booming when you're not
heavy anymore or you're you went through
a divorce and you feel amazing or you
cured this illness naturally when you're
on the other side how could you not be
happy
this is what you do but you must go back
in time and remember that pain it's easy
to live where you are you must go back
and remember that pain because some
people are in it and you have to help
them move away from that pain
does that make sense
and you have to also
only half the people want to move away
from pain
some people are in good shape but they
want to become Olympic style athletes
maybe you have a boot camp weekend that
would kill anybody in good shape and put
them on a whole nother level they're not
really moving away from Pain they're
doing okay physically but they want to
be a badass they want to be the top one
percent you have to paint the picture of
the pleasure of where they want to go
they want to move towards a bigger
future
somebody why if somebody's 100 pounds
overweight and they're sick of being out
of breath they have diabetes they want
to fix this they want to move away from
the pain of being overweight and what
that caused them right
but once they lose that weight and
they're feeling good where they might
want to go they want to might might want
to move towards going to a whole nother
level and doing marathons that's moving
towards okay so remember you're going to
want to really live inside the mind of
your prospect of what is their pain in
most cases you went through that pain at
some point in your life
you say what pain I don't think Tina
didn't go through pain because she's
teaching people how to get loans she
kind of went through some pain she went
through some pain of working 60 hour
weeks and at the end of the month
collect 50 000 bucks and be like yay and
there's 49 972 dollars in bills and all
of a sudden pain like I'm not really in
business I'm kind of in business I
pretend to be in business my family
thinks I'm in business but there's no
money left she had that pain right she
can remember that as it drives her
forward so really live inside the mind
of your prospect know their pain
what do they want to move away from what
do they want to move towards you want
you want my secret on how to do it
but my secret on who feels when I hope
this is like I'm looking for a pat on
the back I'm not really who feels
sometimes when I share
that I'm talking directly to you you're
like man how does he know I feel that
way
can I give you a little secret
I read hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of your posts
I'm kind of smart but I'm not that smart
I let you tell me
I read your posts obsessively I read
your posts when you don't think I'm
watching like right now you're giving me
all Kudos Dean you're great that's
awesome you might be in like one of the
groups saying Dean you're you know you
suck or whatever right I read all of it
but I Read When You're vulnerable and
say I'd love to do this but I'm feeling
scared right now and I feel like this
might not be the right path or I'm I'm
reading those so I'm addressing today
because I'm reading the pain
that you want to move away from and I'm
reading the pleasure of where you want
to go to so read obsessively if you
don't have a following yet where people
are go find somebody that's similar in
your business find a Facebook group that
is around menopause or loans or health
or life or family or business or Fitness
find another one and go there and just
start asking questions what's your
biggest obstacle when it comes to health
what are you afraid the most that you're
going through a divorce what does it
feel like to be a woman who's a mom has
a business and trying to be a husband
and lost their self there's nothing on
the inside I'm like a shell I want my
heart back go find a group like that and
ask and find out those those they'll
tell you the pain and they'll tell you
what they want what they want as
pleasure and we get to live inside the
mind of the person we want to serve
make sense
it's a little cheat sheet
the last one
um
the last one is as we move forward as
you take the uncomfortable action
and you start getting momentum are we
here just to make a sale
are we here to make a sale are we here
to turn this into a business right is I
told you that silly fishing story
yesterday
but what I want you to do is if we think
back to that crazy analogy
is just because I was catching fish
do you think I settled
okay I'm gonna give you that I know it
was such a silly dumb story but I like I
like things that stick right when I want
to tell you when I started sneaking up
to the water I'm not embellishing any of
this this is true when I started either
hiding behind a tree or sneaking up and
then
casting my line I started catching fish
when no one else did
to me that was listen to this word that
was my new control
the control was Dean sneaks up to the
water you catch fish
but do you think was I satisfied with
that
once I knew sneaking up got me more fish
you know what I said
what what else can I do
I realized that if I landed the fly
right behind a little rapid on the other
side of a rock or underside of a log man
as soon as it landed I'd get a hit what
was my new control
sneak up
and land the fly in that spot but then I
realized when it landed I had so much
line out that when the fish would hit I
wouldn't be there to tug it to kind of
set the hook so then I learned I gotta
sneak up I gotta land it right there and
I gotta pull all the slack out of the
line so when the fish hits the fly I
could tug it stick the hook I reel it in
get a cool picture kiss them put them
back in the Water right
I didn't say I wasn't satisfied with the
first one what was I doing my control
was sneak up
but I obsessed on beating the control
my obsession is always if you talk to
anyone in my company I feel blessed I
get to run Tony's company too they'll
tell you one thing about me
it's not that I'm never satisfied I'm
satisfied every day in my life I'm never
satisfied with the control because I
know it can always be better I have 25
years doing this and whenever it's good
I know there's another level and
whenever that's good I know there's
another level I also know that
eventually whatever marketing you do
whatever you're going to have to create
a new message a different message an
alternative message and all of a sudden
you'll create a message and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is understand the
strategy with Russell Brunson for those
who are just tuning in my name is
Russell Brunson and I'm excited to have
you guys here I'm answering a whole
bunch of amazing questions from
entrepreneurs like you about how to grow
and scale your companies and do your
funnels and a whole bunch of other
awesome stuff so the question for right
now for today is the best advice it says
can you pull the curtains back and tell
me your best advice and how I should go
about getting started as an entrepreneur
okay so this is
um this is one of the problems a lot of
entrepreneurs have right is that first
if you want to be an entrepreneur
there's a lot of things right there's a
lot of pieces that go involved in doing
this right and for some reason when we
become entrees think we had to become
amazing at all those things I'm not sure
why we do but that's pretty Universal
for most of us right and so what happens
is we get in this thing where we're it's
probably because we went to school and
most of us didn't like school we
struggled through school but we get done
we're like I want to be an entrepreneur
this is the platform to be
I'm going to be an entrepreneur you're
standing on this thing like hey to be an
entrepreneur what I got to do and you're
like okay first off I gotta have like
vision and then second off I gotta build
a team and then third off I gotta learn
programming and I got to learn graphic
design they got to learn and you have
all this list of all the stuff you got
to do right and so you standing there
you're like I gotta become an
entrepreneur I gotta learn all these
things then all of a sudden
super overwhelming right it's a lot of
things that actually goes into that and
so what I recommend for entrepreneurs if
you really want to have success it's not
so much trying to figure out all those
different things okay the goal of the
entrepreneur is not to learn how to do
every single piece in this puzzle okay
the golden entrepreneur
is number one is to understand the
strategy
of what you're doing
okay the number two
is to figure out the system
and number three is to build the team
okay so that's the three-step process
and I want to liken this to something
that most of us are aware of and makes
common sense so let's just say you went
to school instead of skating on the
platform of I'm gonna be an entrepreneur
you said I'm going to become a
contractor I'm gonna build houses and so
let's say you do that right and so you
get over here and you stand on this
platform of like I am a contractor and
I'm going to be building houses all day
right now for some reason the rest of
the world understands its best
entrepreneurs don't we think we have to
understand and learn how to do
everything but a contractor does not go
and try to figure out I gotta learn
plumbing and I gotta learn electrical
work I gotta learn how to do drywall I
got to learn how to slice them in no
right what does the contractor do the
contractors understand the strategy how
do you actually build a house what are
the things you need who are the people
you need like what's the raw materials
what's the order has to go and what goes
first we'll go second and that's the
goal of this contract right to
understand the strategy okay then the
contractor put together systems you
gotta get blueprints of like hey this is
what we're gonna do and then he's got to
get the team assembled okay you're the
dude who's gonna lay the foundation
you're the dude who's doing the pipes
you're the guy doing the electricity
you're the person doing the roofs and he
builds the people and then the
contractor gets paid the biggest bucks
right so we got to start stop thinking
ourselves as entrepreneurs you have to
learn everything and look at ourselves
the same way a contractor would your
goal as an entrepreneurs not to learn
everything is to understand the strategy
okay that's why I tell people to read my
books like read the expert Secrets book
read the.com Secrets because these books
teach you the strategies what you have
to learn to understand but after you
understand the strategy then it's like
hey what's the system we're going to do
we need a funnel to make this whole
thing happen Okay the funnel hacker
cookbook for those who haven't had this
this has got like 20 different funnel
structures okay it's the systems behind
how to build a funnel today cool I know
what executing our vision we need this
funnel right here on page whatever right
now you've got the system now you've got
to build a team who are the team of
people who are going to help us execute
on this okay I know I need a designer I
need a funnel Builder I need a
copywriter I need it and you kind of
figure out who the team is you assemble
those things together and you go and you
do it now some of you guys are wondering
like Russell that's gonna be hard I
don't have the I don't have the money
for this and all those kind of things
but I want to understand it's the same
way that I started away most most
successful entrepreneurs started right I
didn't build click funnels just off of
like me being a genius because I'm not
ask my team like there's very few things
I'm good at right but what am I good at
I understand the strategy okay I put
together systems make it happen and we
built a team of amazing people okay just
sitting in this room right now I've got
people here who Drive traffic who do our
Instagram who do our video who do our
like uh copy we do our like all the all
the people I've assembled but I don't
know how to do any of the pieces I don't
know how to go and lay the piping or the
electricity or any of those things right
I just understand the overarching
strategy so if you use the entrepreneur
that's your number one Focus okay so if
you're looking like let me pull back the
curtains it's like hey guess what
Russell's not actually Superman he's not
actually that good at many things the
one thing he's good at understanding the
strategy of where we're trying to go
with our vision okay and we understand
that like that's the key that's your job
as an entrepreneur understand the
strategy okay think about Steve Jobs and
the greatest entrepreneurs of Our
Lifetime right with Steve Jobs a
programmer no was he a designer no he
couldn't do any of those things right
but he had the vision this is what I
want this is a strategy okay you start
putting together a team you got Wozniak
you guys other people build out the team
and Boom Out came Apple okay same
thing's gonna be true for you guys um
understand that that's your job as an
entrepreneurs understand the strategy
create the systems and build the team
and that's how you start scaling and
growing an actual company
there's a reason why
true you you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something you are the best the
absolute best at something in the world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that their world
class has something or two they found
the thing that they could be world class
at but they don't have enough guts to
chase it down they don't believe in
themselves enough to chase them down
here's the thing you need to First
explore you need to explore you got to
search you got to say yes you got to try
things you don't know that that Tim
Hortons is your favorite coffee cup
until you've tried it right you don't
know that Sushi is your favorite food
until you've tried it so she doesn't
make sense
right this is how we think our logical
brain starts to analyze things and
because it doesn't make sense we don't
try it Sushi doesn't make sense you're
gonna take raw fish mix it with rice put
seaweed around it and then eat it that
sounds nasty right if you've never tried
it before it sounds nasty but best
a lot of the things that you might be
great at you are a judge and you are
dismissing because it doesn't make
logical sense you don't need to wrap
your head around it you need to wrap
your heart around it you have to feel it
you have to say yes and be willing to
try at least once if you don't know what
you're great at you have to say yes and
try things and you pay attention to the
feeling
the most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it I expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
to suck at the beginning you're gonna
suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again what would the boldest
version of you do think about your
mission think about your goals think
about what you are trying to accomplish
you've got what you're doing now but
think about what the boldest version of
you if you summon the boldest version of
you into existence right now what would
he or she tell you to do so when I did
my tour earlier this year it was 90 days
23 cities and at first I want to do it
for free I love doing free coffee shop
meetups every time I travel to a new
city and I told my agent Steve from New
York hey man this is my idea he said you
need to charge for the event you got to
play bigger you gotta you gotta do a
bolder version of you and it it's
freaked me out it scared me because I
don't want to disappoint people in the
idea of charging for something and then
me disappointing people and then hitting
that fear every four days because I got
up in a new city every three to four
days for 90 days was me being able to
conquer my fears and so Steve pushed me
and and I have Steve's voice in my head
she's like you need to play bigger you
got to do something Bolder what's the
next step and so I'm looking at my next
tour coming up in 2020 around my book
built the serve and I'm trying to think
how do I make it even bigger how do I
make it even Bolder because what I've
done has been great and it's not trying
to take away from what I've done it's
amazing I'm proud of myself I'm grateful
awesome and I know I'm capable of more
and I know I need to do something at the
next level because if I want to go off
and accomplish my mission I need to
because at the rate I'm going right now
I'm not going to hit a billion people
I'm not going to solve the world's
biggest problem
I'm not gonna have the impact and reach
that I know I can't have unless I demand
more boldness bigger scale from myself
on a daily basis and so for me having
Steve's voice in my head having Elon
musk's voice in my head having Steve
Jobs and apagenini and my parents and
Kanye West and Howard Schultz constantly
in my head the content that I make is
for myself
it's selfish for myself and then I share
with you guys and thankfully you like it
so I could build a business around it
and hire your team and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you summon that
creature on a daily basis when you if
you wake up and you daily every day
consistently are bringing the boldest
version of you even for one year if you
woke up every day for one year and
summoned the boldest version of you your
life is gonna look dramatically
different one year from today stop
thinking that you should be Fearless if
you go through life Fearless that means
you are playing small and not doing
anything that is worth doing you should
be dreaming big you should be pushing
boundaries and in that push comes fear
instead of trying to be Fearless adopt a
mindset that you want to feel the fear
and do it anyway otherwise you will
never tick on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission and you'll
always live below the potential that you
know you're capable of not asking for
help is selfish you might think that
trying to do everything yourself is
selfless that it's wrong to ask for help
and Noble to do everything yourself but
you love helping people you love helping
others remember that Joy you feel when
you help somebody and brought a smile to
their face knowing you made their week
by you not asking for help you're
cheating people of that opportunity to
bring a smile to their face stop being
selfish and start asking for help I came
up with this idea when I was at a video
game Cafe so here's what happened I was
I was on a call with one of my big
customers at the time and I was in Los
Angeles and we're doing a Google live
streaming to my YouTube channel lots of
people watching YouTube live I'm
interviewing him and then the internet
goes down like what happened the power
went out across all of Los Angeles the
power goes out and it and it's down I
got nothing the stream is still live but
I'm not there anymore I left my client
live on the stream and he's he's not
sure what happens he just sees my camera
goes down and then he keeps going by
himself and another 15-20 minutes
waiting for me to come back and he's
he's embarrassed and it's awkward and he
doesn't know what he's doing because the
host
who has the audience there is now gone
and then eventually he just leaves
because he said well I don't know where
Evan is but
thank you guys for watching and it put
him in a really difficult situation I
felt terrible I went back to watching
the live stream after like oh my God I
can't believe that happened now it's out
of my control like you know the internet
goes down in Los Angeles what am I
supposed to do there's no power anywhere
so as soon as the power gets back up I
messaged my my client and say hey man
I'm really sorry about that let's
reschedule it let's do it again when I'm
back home in Toronto where I know I have
stable internet and and I want to do it
again for free no extra cost uh even
though we had almost finished the live
stream together we're gonna do a whole
other one for free just because I want
you to I want to make this right for you
great so we come back to Toronto it's
like the a week or two later and my
internet is pretty Rock Solid in my home
office I've never had an internet issue
really happen while I was doing a live
stream but I wanted to make extra sure
extra sure that this time nothing
happened because if something happened
the second time
just it would not be a good thing so I
asked my friend J rise and said J rise I
need I need a place that has Rock Solid
internet that I'm gonna do this live
stream and nothing can go wrong
and he said I got a place as an internet
cafe that got that I go to I'll
introduce you to the owner I know him
and and you can do it there like thank
you so much so we go there I'm there an
hour early I'm setting up I'm talking to
the owner I'm testing the gear my
microphone the headset all of it the
camera testing all of it just to make
sure that everything is working smoothly
I'm nervous because the last time it
failed on us my client comes on we go
live for half an hour an hour I don't
remember and and it was smooth perfect
no issues crisp amazing internet blazing
fast speeds great time with the audience
and we delivered an awesome product
sigh of relief right I'm so pumped I go
talk to the owner and say dude thank you
man it was perfect no complaints no
problems thank you so much how much do I
owe you
and he said well you are on the computer
for about an hour and a half and j-rod
is on the computer for about an hour and
a half but I'll just bundle it together
so
I think what he told me was like five
bucks or seven bucks or ten bucks or
something like are you kidding me I
would have paid a thousand dollars I
would have paid a lot of money just to
make sure that this went smoothly
because it's the it's the relationship
with my client at the time right I said
okay well let me great here's here's the
seven dollars that you wanted awesome
let me buy let me buy some some stuff
from behind the counter let me buy some
snacks from my friend Jerry Rice jairo's
was hungry he needed to eat so like here
here's 20 bucks 25 bucks let me just buy
out a whole bunch of your snacks and
give it to him he's like no no you don't
have to do that man don't worry about it
like no I want to do it let me buy the
snack no no don't worry about it
the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought
that he was being selfless that hey
don't worry but you don't have to do it
that just just paying for the internet
was enough for him but he was actually
being selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he cheated me of the opportunity
of one saying thank you I wanted to pay
more I want to pay more you're cheating
me of the opportunity to do it and
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
help my friend J rise and give him some
food because he was hungry so we had to
go somewhere else you need to be willing
to to bring other people in you need to
be willing to ask for help
yes you don't want to waste your time
yes you want to be respectful yes but
people love helping others we are built
to serve you want to help other people
that joy that you feel when you help
somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too if you quit on something too
soon that you still love you will regret
it for the rest of your life if you
don't love it anymore quit move on you
will never win doing work that you hate
but if you love it you love it and you
move on to something else you will look
back on this day and regret it for the
rest of your life that you did not see
it through most people spend their
entire life living with regrets don't
let that be you the hardest decision I
ever had to make in my life was being an
entrepreneur I struggled a lot with the
decision do I want to be an entrepreneur
and had this opportunity to make 300 a
month and earn 30 of a company versus
going to work at a job that I thought I
wanted a job that I've been preparing
myself for that this is what I wanted to
do it was in my high school yearbook of
this is where I was going to be and here
it was earning six figures traveling
around the world doing the investment
banking I thought I wanted to do versus
making 300 a month and only only owning
30 of a company and the thing that
allowed me to push through and be an
entrepreneur was me saying I don't want
to live with regret
that I would rather no one fail than not
know
and I gave myself a year I said I'm
going to give myself a year to do this I
could always go back and get another job
I may not be the same job it probably
wouldn't be the same job may not be as
much pay may not be traveling as much as
this job was off for me to travel but
this entrepreneurial thing this
opportunity that I had
I never knew if it would come back again
like I thought maybe this will never
happen to me again and so I decided to
go for it and we struggled and and it
was hard but I never ended up having to
go back and get another job
and so if you're at an inflection point
if you're thinking about which path
should I take a or b
lean in with your heart stop using your
head your head only understands the
world that currently exists lean in with
your heart
and ask yourself which decision will I
regret more if I don't do and then go
take that action
I became an entrepreneur because I
didn't want to regret not having at
least tried
and a great moment in my life came a
number of years later but one of the
people I went to University with came
back and said Evan
I went down that path I became the
investment banker and I hate my life how
do I become an entrepreneur
and I looked in his eyes and I saw the
desperation and the sadness and helped
him but also was so grateful that that
wasn't me because it could have been
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how you can build a six-figure business
check the interview I did with Natalie
Ellis right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I wanted to just
start a community on Boss baby selfishly
for myself that I would have a place to
go and making sure you're moving forward
and not backwards that we've focused on
one thing at a time what are some of the
key things